[Musique]
avec son neveu resus remoulou Kandia
nous conduit vers la tombe de son frère
Raymond tu es d'une balle de fusil dans
la manifestation du 11 janvier à Cusco
nous sommes au cimetière d'Anta petite
ville qui domine la vallée à une
trentaine de kilomètres de Costco
[Musique]
des centaines de personnes ont
accompagné raymo jusqu'à sa sépulture
[Musique]
il laisse un fils de 19 ans et deux
autres enfants de 8 et 10 ans leur mère
et toute la grande famille Candia
clodoï dans la famille
celle du patriarche et frahin décédé en
novembre dernier et maintenant l'un des
6 enfants Raymond de Léopolda Guevara
doute sur qui a tué son frère la police
parce que la balle est venue du côté de
la police il était visé d'hiromulo
c'était planifié sinon il y aurait eu
d'autres morts il a été le seul et par
une balle de gros calibre un fusil
cela mettait pour protester pourquoi
pour protester dans la rue pour faire
respecter nos droits mon frère n'est pas
un criminel ou un terrorisme
en fait Remo était un leader paysan
d'une des 13 régions du département de
Cusco un chef local pas un grand
dirigeant national ni provincial
[Musique]
les descendants des Incas fier de leur
pampas cette vallée fertile à 3300
mètres d'altitude
dès l'enfant que chaque membre de la
famille à sa chakra son lointain terre
la famille Candia possède au total deux
hectares
le lien avec la terre est très profond
l'agriculture au Pérou c'est une
relation
essentiellement culturelle avec le
territoire ingénieur agronome spécialisé
dans la gestion de l'eau Marx Racer
fréquente les communautés rurales de
Cusco depuis 40 ans on est ancré sur un
territoire on a une relation
même magique
religieuse avec avec ce territoire avec
les montagnes avec les avec les lacs
avec les avec les rivières la famille
cultive le maïs les fèves et le quinoa
et qu'on met son dans cette cave passe
nos parents et grands-parents nous ont
éduqué avec le peu d'argent qu'il
gagnait en vendant le reste de la
production une fois la famille nourrie
les paysans du Pérou ne peuvent plus
compter sur la seule agriculture pour
survivre il se livre à d'autres
activités le commerce de leur surplus de
produits pour commencer
Léopold Dag et vara tient une petite
épicerie dans le coin de la maison
familiale elle a une éducation primaire
et frahine son mari secondaire il était
devenu technicien agricole
qui était un alphabète ils ont tous
sacrifié pour l'éducation de leurs
enfants Romeo est anthropologue
Remo était comptable pro c'est ingénieur
géologue les soeurs sont
administratrices institutrices
ingénieurs une belle réussite cette
famille ambitieuse souhaite que leurs
enfants soient entrepreneurs
dans leur temps libre c'est un devoir
sacré
[Musique]
on n'est plus dans la situation des
années 60-70 sous le paysan était
seulement producteur agréable
mais donc ce qui fait des gens que ces
familles paysages elles sont en relation
avec le monde urbain le monde disons
dominant
et elles sont évidemment très au courant
de ce qui se passe dans dans le pays et
dans le monde et ce qui se passe dans
les Andes la sierraminière au nord et
l'Amazonie des régions indigènes c'est
le manque de retombées locales pour les
richesses qu'elles envoient à Lima
tourisme gaz naturel minerai produit
agricole manque de service Anta n'a pas
le courant Kuzco n'a pas le gaz de ville
qu'il produit mais qui va en gazoduc
Alima
ce manque de services est une injustice
il y a un manque de retombée il y a un
manque de d'investissement de l'état de
présence de l'État en quantité et en
qualité c'est à dire une de services
services de santé service de
d'éducation route
communication internet etc etc et pas de
représentation congrès c'est pour tout
ça que le sud paysan est monté à Lima
pour exiger des
le respect de leur coutume et la fin
d'un racisme qui perdure depuis la
colonie espagnole
parce que
dans la chambre de Rémo il y a une photo
de lui en costume de danseur Quechua
fier de leur traditions
ont ressuscité une danse de la victoire
du temps des Incas
la saxempire la danse des princes des
petites pierres
les pierres que les guerriers lancés
avec leur fronde
les élèves de la faculté de
communication de Cusco sont venus faire
un reportage sur cette danse avec leur
professeur anthropologue à Anta son
origine
le danseur a du mal rosé qui avec ses
frères la danse et pendant toute sa
jeunesse et celle de lui montrer des
voiles
sont notre contribution à notre peuple
notre Terre notre pays
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'au funérailles de
Raymond il y avait tous ses danseurs
[Musique]
de mes trois neveux nous avons porté
plainte mais nous ne voulons plus de
mort mort de paysans fils de paysan de
leader paysan la famille Kandia veut que
justice soit